the current wars number eight amazing
252 and now of venom block party how the
world of comics has changed we are here
live on Melrose experiencing the
pinnacle of comic dumb it's crazy
with todd mcfarlane in the mind of todd
mcfarlane what is it like being an event
that literally sprang from your own mind
years ago
flattering right sort of sort of cool
the thing that's interesting when you
see the success of something like venom
and and I had no giant impact on that
movie in any level is it is it I liken
myself to the parents that you see when
somebody makes their major league debut
yeah so for people who are not sports
fans is how it work you just go oh my
God look our little boy Tommy and Tommy
we raised them right and after all this
time and all that work he's on the field
but at the end of the day Tommy needs to
stand on his own and he has to hit the
curveball and all's we are just
cheerleaders right so to me venom now
has people that are supporting him in
different ways and Sony and the movie
makers in Rubin who who did it in the
cast and and Tom Hardy did a great job
being Eddie Brock and and I'm just sort
of a proud papa with a big smile up in
the third deck smiling down hoping that
they hit a home run and they hit a grand
slam with the billion dollar venom that
they did so it's it's interesting but
I'm not I'm not necessary to the process
now which is which which which you want
for everything that you create
creatively that your your creations
should be able to survive - the
originator right and and I always look
to somebody like Walt Disney not Channel
Walt Disney so don't mistake me but Walt
Disney that isn't on the planet anymore
and yet his characters will live and
just recently a good friend of mine Stan
Lee passed away and all of his
characters are gonna live which means
those ideas
we're just so good they're gonna survive
the father the creative fathers of them
I never be I'm hoping that some of my
ideas live past my lifetime too and
you've seen the rise of comics you were
there when the giant explosion of
multiple covers and all these things are
happening and now we're seeing it with
comic films does it feel familiar in
this explosion of pop culture awareness
for comic books it's it what's what's
interesting is some of the reasons that
people got excited about comic books
when I was younger because I've been
around this business now for over 30
years and and the reason that they sort
of you know take sort of attention of
certain villains and certain heroes they
go oh my god I like that and I like that
story all those same things are now
being trapped transferred to the movie
or it's at it or the TV and so when I'm
hearing people describe why they like
the movies and why they like certain
characters I'm hearing the same
conversations that I I used to be in
myself 20-30 years ago and that and now
but they're doing it with movie and TV
and they don't have to collect comic
book right to make a billion dollars on
something like venom we know
mathematically the vast majority people
have not read a venom comic book right
especially internationally because
people don't even in some countries
don't even have access to American comic
books so you just go they're just going
to what's on the screen and to them
that's what their their vantage point is
right and then the reactant from that
vantage point and all the history that
led up to it that's your beaks like you
and I to have these big panels and
discussion it's not necessary again
right just like I'm not necessary to the
process then the 30 year history to some
extent isn't overly necessary it's that
two hours spread out over a globe to
billions of people how many will come
and react to that right
we're here and they're doing it in real
time in front of us that the the world's
this world building is growing in front
of our eyes
essentially but we're seeing it being
built yeah and so our children are gonna
be born into world in which it just will
be right and we're gonna go while we
were there when it first started I saw
the first Batman movie the first
spider-man movie we're gonna be sounding
like dinosaurs cap had a rubber ears
when I was a kid lion my day right and
and and so there go oh my god that's
kind of cool but it's just gonna be part
of the vernacular we're just we're I
think we're just fortunate right now to
just see it standing right in front of
us and we got a front-row seat all this
like a Symbian expanding in front of us
we're seeing the growth of the comic
world
now you redefined a lot of the visuals
of spider-man you go over you change the
webbing you changed how we posed you
changed a lot of the visual aesthetic
and you're doing something similar it
sounds like with spawn you're changing
an entire aesthetic to the superhero
genre is it interesting to be someone
that goes like that's working let's go
this direction is that a conscious
decision it's yes and here's why because
artistically I would do it just for
career survival because because in the
business of comic books there there are
hundreds if not thousands of artists
right so how do you stick out right and
the only way you can stick out is that
you got to start doing things that might
be interesting or it might be fun to
look at and so every character that I
did there's there's really two things
that are driving me one I've got to
survive and and I don't want to just be
lost in the shuffle
and the sea of other creative people
because they're brilliant and the other
part was and I don't think people really
quite understand this concept that when
you're doing comic book he's doing
writing comic books or novels or
whatever else but let's just stick with
comic my days were 10 to 12 hours a day
in a room
small room at my desk with me and so so
there's no outside influence it's just
you were the desk yeah and so the number
one rule at least for me I don't know
how others do it was I I want to draw
fun I want to I want to draw stuff
that's cool yeah so then you channel
your inner ten-year-old and you go oh my
god that would be cool if I'm drawing
the Hulk I'm going what would be fun to
draw on and you'd be any crushes then
and if I'm doing spider-man I go oh I
want him to do that flip around like
he's a bug and if he's Batman I want to
have the big giant cape and every
everything I was doing was just what's
gonna get me through the deadline and is
it fun to draw and then I crossed my
fingers and hope that the readers would
basically respond to it right and if
that works then you also then start
creating a style and then the style
helps your career and so I'm not trying
to say oh that's wrong or that's bad I'm
just trying to say I've seen that look
let me try a different look not better
not worse just different yeah and that
brings you to my final question for you
your very stylistic approach to these
characters in a very bold approach has
brought two of the most interesting
action blockbuster slash nuanced actors
to them you've got jeremy renner and
you've got tom hardy two guys known for
being like Oscar thespian comma action
guys do you think it's a coincidence
that these characters multi dynamic
personality brought these crazy multi
damage actors people say a lot of nice
things about my career and and I
appreciate it but I think that if you
just create interesting ideas then
they're just naturally gonna draw
people's curiosity if you have the kids
and your kids love that then they'll
talk your kids can talk they can do so
Tom Hardy has a kid and like venom so
he's like yeah I'm gonna go do venom
he's gonna be the coolest bad right
I'm betting his kids not saying dad you
were so cool and in the Reverend right
I don't think so he's probably going
down I don't even understand what that
movie was about how come you didn't get
the wrestled a bear and how come you
were so dirty but that Emily you're kind
of cool and guess what everybody on the
block thinks you're cool right now right
a mini made the coolest looking
character go right away dad he's a
coolest dad on his block yeah yeah well
I'm insane that this is become from all
the bread it's incredible
congratulations and all this madness and
image venom comes out on Tuesday the
18th it's got tons of special features
you can see all of this and more check
it out pick it up
[Music]